salut romain ça ouais parce que tu crois
ah bon c'est à dire ouais tu vois ce que
tu crois
ouais ok t'as juste eu le titre de la
vidéo en fait c'est ça aussi à la
migraine
vous vous souvenez on en a déjà parlé
avec le poney et la piscine c'est
l'excusé la plus utilisée pour la faire
toutes sortes de choses qu'on n'a pas
envie de faire en fait il ya deux
problèmes
certains s'en servent comme d'une excuse
effectivement et puis on dit qu'on a la
migraine
quand on ajuste mal à la tête le
problème c'est que 1
la migraine c'est pas un simple mal de
tête et deux à force d'employer le terme
à tort et à travers
on décrédibilise ceux qui en souffrent
vraiment pire parfois il se soigne pas
correctement parce qu'ils pensent que
c'est pas vraiment une maladie
d'ailleurs plus de la moitié des
patients savent même pas qu'ils font des
migraines
alors on va mettre les choses au point
tout de suite la migraine ça n'est pas
du cinéma
ça n'est pas dans la tête enfin si mais
pas au sens psychologique ça n'est pas
juste un mal de tête
la migraine c'est une vraie maladie est
encore nier contrairement à ce qu'on
peut entendre parfois c'est une maladie
qui touche les femmes et les hommes bon
mais alors il grain mal de tête
c'est quoi la différence ok donc déjà je
vous vois faire la moue donc on va se
mettre d'accord mis dans la migraine
il y a une histoire de mal de tête mais
pas un mal de tête classique pas une
simple céphalées comme on dit dans le
jargon et dans dr house d'abord les
céphalées migraineuses on les a par
crise elle dure plusieurs heures à
plusieurs jours
et elles se répètent régulièrement
ensuite c'est une douleur particulière
elle peut être modérées ou fortes mais
elles arrivent progressivement et on dit
qu'elle est pulsatile comme si on
sentait son coeur battre dans son crâne
avec parfois la sensation dans la tête
dans un étau et pour finir elle peut ne
toucher que la moitié de la tête et elle
est souvent aggravée par des activités
minime des mouvements simples comme
monter un escalier ou juste faire
quelques pas alors elle n'a pas
forcément toutes ces particularités mais
si elle en a au moins deux sur les
quatre cantons fait une migraine on peut
aussi ressentir d'autres signes comme
des nausées voire des vomissements ou ne
plus supporter la lumière et le bruit au
point de devoir aller s'allonger dans le
noir au calme dans 70% des cas la
migraine c'est ça mais pour les 30%
restants via un petit bonus qui
s'appelle laura pas le prénom c'est une
aura une aura c'est un ensemble de
signes pénible vous en doutez bien
qu'ils apparaissent juste avant le mal
de tête
ça peut être des troubles de la vue
comme des petits points lumineux où des
taches noires qui empêche de voir
correctement on appelle ça des
phosphates et des scot hommes
oui c'était joli mot mais ça peut être
flippant ça c'est plus fréquent mais ça
peut aussi être des fourmis ou des
engourdissements au niveau des doigts du
visage des jambes et là encore ça ne
peut toucher que la moitié du corps
pour finir on peut aussi avoir du mal à
parler chercher ses mots ou en employant
pour un autre quand on n'est pas habitué
ça peut faire peur en réalité ce sont
des symptômes neurologiques
parce que oui la migraine c'est par là
que ça se passe au niveau des nerfs donc
et des vaisseaux sanguins
en fait on sait pas encore tout ce qui
se passe de façon très précise mais on
n'en sait quand même de plus en plus sur
la façon dont ça se déclenche
ça commence dans l'hypothalamus on en a
déjà parlé c'est pas un resto de
grillades c'est cette petite partie de
votre cerveau donc l'hypothalamus il
s'excite et il excite les neurones et
les terminaisons nerveuses des artères
de la membrane qui entoure le cerveau
qu'on appelle la dure-mère dans
l'excitation les nerfs libère des
substances chimiques qui provoquent
l'inflammation et la dilatation des
artères et c'est ça qui fait mal et
c'est pour ça que ça pulse et pour laura
ça se passe au niveau du cortex le
cortex est une substance grise de
quelques millimètres qui recouvre aussi
le cerveau et qui gère des fonctions
neurologiques très important et le
cortex bail il est perturbé par toute
cette excitation autour de lui on
appelle ça la dépression corticale
envahissant et suivant la zone touchée
ça donne les signes dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure mais entre les crises tout
redevient en valeur pas de panique ok
mais alors à la base qu'est ce qui lui
prend à l'hypothalamus de faire son
malin comme ça voilà c'est là que ça se
complique ce qu'on sait c'est que
génétiquement les gens qui font des
migraines ont un cerveau plus sexy table
que les autres plus sensible si vous
voulez vous savez un peu comme votre
pote qui stresse pour un rien voilà ce
qui serait ce le cerveau c'est les
changements arpa décalé une nuits plus
courtes ou plus longue que d'habitude
une émotion quelle qu'elle soit un
bouleversement hormonal paf ça peut
déclencher une crise de migraine
bon vous allez peut-être me dire ok
c'est bon on a compris mais globalement
ça reste un mal de tête
donc on s'en fout et là je vais vous
dire non pas du tout tandis que les mois
non pas du tout ah ben je vous avais
prévenu était important savoir faire la
différence parce que une migraine ça se
soigne pas de la même façon qu'un simple
mal de crâne pire le risque c'est de
prendre un médicament pour caler votre
mal de crâne que ça marche pas bien donc
d'en prendre un autre puis d'essayer
autre chose et c est ça ça aggrave les
choses
oui prendre trop de médicaments ça peut
déclencher des céphalées donc on s'en
sort pas et puis surtout quand c'est mal
ou pas soigner ça peut devenir un vrai
handicap que ce soit sur le plan
professionnel ou personnel
parce que quand on a une migraine on est
parfois incapables de faire quoi que ce
soit tant que c'est pas passé et qu'une
personne atteinte de migraine à trois à
quatre fois plus de risques de
développer une dépression que les autres
oui du coup vous avez compris la
migraine ça se soigne en plus des
traitements classiques et des
traitements spécifiques de la crise de
migraine des traitements pour diminuer
la douleur pendant les crises et même
des traitements préventifs pour diminuer
le nombre de crises si elles sont très
fréquentes
donc si vous avez un doute n'hésitez pas
à en parler à votre médecin
allez on récapitule si vous avez
régulièrement des crises de maux de tête
qui arrive progressivement et qui dure
entre 4 heures et trois jours si la
douleur correspond à celle qu'on a
décrit tout à l'heure avec en plus un
des deux autres signes dont on a parlé
prenez rendez vous chez votre médecin
encore plus si tout ça est précédé d'une
aura avec un des trois signes que vous
connaissez maintenant
et attention la migraine c'est pas aussi
courant qu'un simple mal de tête et
c'est pas une maladie rare pour autant
ça touche un adulte sur cinq en france
c'est pas une maladie mortelle mais ça a
des répercussions importantes sur la vie
quotidienne et ça soigne mais pas
n'importe comment
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout
[Applaudissements]